[Musica]
avete mai riflettuto sul fatto che la
libertà di movimento è un privilegio
nonostante migrare sia un diritto
sancito dalla dichiarazione universale
dei diritti umani
Esiste un forte Un forte asimmetria che
riguarda la libertà di movimento
il tasso di rifiuti dei visti di
ingresso in Italia
è raddoppiato in pochi anni
e a ciò si aggiunge le norme
diseguaglianza che separa e passaporti
di serie A dei paesi ricchi occidentali
e i passaporti di serie B
del Sud del mondo
con un passaporto italiano ad esempio
ho libertà di movimento e posso andare
quasi
senza chiedere un visto
dappertutto ovunque
col mio passaporto tunisino
No non mi ha consentito
per questo motivo che non scappa da
guerra o da un particolare situazione di
instabilità ma vuole semplicemente
ricercare una vita migliore altrove
e costretto a lungo i viaggi in cui le
probabilità di rischiare la vita
attraversando il deserto
e imbarcando imbarcandosi su un gommone
sono altissimi
e il mar Mediterraneo è stato sempre un
Crocevia in cui le persone e i popoli si
sono incontrati
hanno scambiato merci hanno dialogato
se sono mescolati l'uno con l'altro
contaminandosi
al giorno d'oggi la parola Mediterraneo
evoca gli scenari drammatici
dei morti e di dispersi in mare
che dal 2013 hanno raggiunto hanno
raggiunto numeri che sono anche
difficili da pronunciare
Si parla addirittura di 25.000 persone
migranti uomini donna e bambini
che hanno perso la vita in mare
quanti saremo qui dentro
Riusciamo a darle un peso questa cifra
25.000
25.000 donne Uomini e bambini
quello che sconvolgente però è che ci
siamo abituati alle tragiche United
naufragi dei morti
come se fosse normale abituarsi a tali
tragedia di questa entità le notizie
sull'immigrazione che ogni giorno
riceviamo sono distorti allarmistica e
spesso strumentale a questa o a quella
linea politica
e ci raccontano persone in cerca di una
vita migliore che venga che vengano
percepite o meglio raccontati come se
fosse Un'invasione un fenomeno
ingestibile quello che dimentichiamo
però che un certo numero di lavoratori
stranieri e funzionale all'Italia al
nostro paese per mantenere il suo
livello di produttività
i dati parlano di circa 200.000 unità
lavorativa se vogliamo quantificare
Attualmente le straniere residenti in
Italia sono circa 5 milioni cioè
l'8,8 della popolazione italiana che
contribuiscono alla crescita del nostro
della nostra economia e del nostro
gettito fiscale
malgrado questo l'Italia e l'Europa
nonostante abbiano sottoscritto
normativa e Convenzione che tutelano il
diritto di asilo
perpetuano ormai da anni
a forma di contrasto all'immigrazione
che secondo i dati del Ministero
dell'Interno aumentano a livello globale
di anno in anno Nel 2020 ad esempio
numero di migranti sbarcati sono i costi
italiane è di circa 33.000 nel 2022
numero sale a circa 95.000 numero di
migranti arrivati solo costa italiane e
triplicato e i motivi sono i più
svariati
instabilità politica del paese di
origine
conflitti guerra cambiamento climatico
mancanza di libertà fondamentalmente
però la spinta maggiore è il forte
desiderio di migliorare la propria vita
quando lavoravo a Lampedusa Ho fatto
l'esperienza più forte umanamente
parlando in prima linea
agli sbarchi o assistito
a scena di gioia immensa per essere
finalmente sulla terraferma
ma anche di profonda tristezza e
sconforto perché il prezzo pagato per
essere arrivati sani e salvi è troppo
alto
ho visto che in quelle traversata delle
speranze ha perso una mamma un papà un
figlio un fratello una sorella un
compagno di viaggio
durante il mio lavoro a contatto con I
migranti ho spesso percepito
l'infrangersi del sogno
di una vita migliore
quello quella immaginata per lungo tempo
E per la quale si è messo a repentaglio
la vita per alcuni le prime avvisaglie
che il percorso non sarebbe stato ha
fatto Semplice si manifesta quando sono
ancora a bordo di navi a cui non vieni
consentito un porto di sbarco
altri sperimentano a terra una realtà
diversa a quella immaginata
con diversi stili di vita tempi
lunghissimi Per la regolarizzazione
Difficoltà di trovare un alloggio e
spesso
vivono sulla propria pelle
discriminazione
razzismo e abusi e i giovani stranieri
sono vittima di una illusione sognano
l'Europa come luogo in cui raggiungere e
Ottenere migliori condizioni di vita
Ma sottovaluta la difficoltà il percorso
tortuoso per l'ottenimento dei documenti
senza il quale non possano lavorare in
maniera regolare
nella maggior parte dei casi
sperimentano l'isolamento in una società
che ne respinge
non li accetta e senza supporto della
propria comunità della famiglia degli
affetti più cari
il ponte di riferimento il rischio per
la salute mentale e forte alcuni a volte
però i problemi psicologici si
manifestano ancora prima quando ad un
certo punto della propria vita
si realizza che non si è diritto di
viaggiare
di spostarsi liberamente e uscire dal
proprio territorio a causa delle
politiche restrittive sui visti e quello
che lo psicologo tunisino weel gare ha
definito trauma della mobilità
L'Europa è presente ovunque nella
cultura
nei media nei social network ma
fisicamente inaccessibile
essere costretti alle mobilità nel
proprio paese genera una sensazione di
reclusione ma soprattutto un desiderio
ancora più forte di andarsene
ecco
io non ho la soluzione al fenomeno
dell'immigrazione
Ma i popoli si sono sempre spostati e
continueranno a farlo ora più che mai
considerata l'urgenza
dettata dai cambiamenti climatici Ma
posso auspicare che venga gestito in
maniera non più emergenziale perché non
è un'emergenza ma un fenomeno
strutturato che va analizzato e gestito
aprendo canale di accessi di accesso
sicuri e legali
esempio il corridoio umanitario sono
un'ottima soluzione che consenta ai
rifugiati di entrare in Italia
in maniera protetta con voli di linea in
questo modo e scongiurato il rischio di
mettersi nelle mani dei trafficanti di
esseri umani sono una valida alternativa
ai morti in mare anche se vieni
selezionato un numero molto ristretto di
persone a fronte di un bacino enorme di
candidati
un'altra cosa
consentire in ingressi legali per motivi
di lavoro e quindi ampliare le quote del
decreto flussi aprendo a anche a
professionalità come quelli che
riguardano i servizi domestici o
assistenza alle persone fragile alle
famiglie per quelli ogni anno cioè
abbastanza domanda che non vengano evasi
la procedura per l'ottenimento del visto
di ingresso non andrebbero non
dovrebbero essere visti come
irraggiungibile andrebbero semplificati
e Resi
decisamente Maggiore ai richiedenti c'è
un altro numero che faccio fatica a
pronunciare perché strida con tutto
quello che fino ad ora fino ad ora è
stato detto
5,8 milioni è il numero degli italiani
all'estero la mobilità italiana dal 2016
dal 2006 scusate dal 2006 ad oggi è
cresciuta del
87%, il sacrosanto diritto sancito dalla
dichiarazione universale dei diritti
umani
di migrare di cercare il benessere
ovunque nel mondo
che in questo caso sì la libertà di
poter scegliere il proprio posto nel
mondo non ha confine la libertà di
movimento non è uguale per tutti la
libertà di movimento è un privilegio
questi sono alcuni delle proposte che mi
passano e mi vengano in te in mente ma è
necessaria una volontà politica e
soprattutto un cambiamento un cambio
dirà relazione su un migranti sugli
stranieri in generale una società
multietnica interculturale esiste già da
tempo ed è stimolante Un incredibile
arricchimento culturale o almeno io la
vivo così
c'è una frase con che contiene un
principio che Q di cui quotidianamente
mi faccio portavoce ed è la frase di Jo
Cox una politica britannica pugnalata e
uccisa in strada da un esponente di
estrema destra all'orlo di Britney first
che dice così abbiamo molto più in
comune di quello che ci divide
Grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]